now we do have some good news today uh
the
biden electoral college vote as of this
moment
is underway it's december 14th
this was the day many trump has said
would be the deadline by which this
would be
completely overturned and today's votes
wouldn't happen
but electors have started casting their
votes for president
around the country there is no doubt
about the winner joe biden today
will officially be the president-elect
now remember
all of these right-wingers who said the
media doesn't decide
who's president-elect well today the
electors
will decide who is president-elect and
joe biden will officially be
president-elect now
in terms of how it's all going to happen
each state
is doing this on their own schedule i
think the first date started
late morning eastern time california
doesn't vote until 5 pm eastern
and at a certain point joe biden will go
over the threshold of 270 electoral
votes
will this be the end of hearing about
these nonsense
claims and theories and bombshells that
are going to interrupt
everything from trumpists it will not
the focus
today will move i believe to january 6th
january 6th is when there is a big
session
of uh of congress where the vice
president mike pence
will be presiding over the formal
counting of these electoral votes
and we are certainly expecting
shenanigans between now
and then and also even conceivably uh i
mean listen if you think back to the
year 2000
the year 2000 al gore as the vice
president had to preside
over the counting when it all came down
in an election he was in to that recount
that was stopped in florida
and there were people who stood up and
said i object to this i object to that
i would imagine that when we have
uh ignorance weaponized to the degree
that it's been weaponized over the last
four or five weeks five weeks since the
election uh we are going to see some
crazy things on december 6. we may even
see some today at uh at the state level
but uh i'm sorry january 6th will be a
day on which we will be seeing
some really really wacky stuff but that
is today
and this will be i mean listen we've
been saying it's over for a while
uh can we say it's extra over after
today
and then after the count is done today
joe biden formally as president-elect of
the united states will be addressing the
nation reportedly around 8 pm eastern
tonight
i will have coverage live on youtube
twitch and facebook tonight starting
shortly before 8 p.m on the east
5 p.m in the west of joe biden's first
address to the nation
officially now officially as
president-elect and i do predict it'll
feel
a little bit different than it did uh
when on that saturday
shortly after the election joe biden
addressed the
nation this is certainly more official
um and we will be together starting
shortly before 8 pm eastern tonight see
you then
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video